FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome to
Talks at Google in Singapore.
We're live here but
there's people also dialing
in from live stream.
And today we're going
to have chef Andre
Chung from Restaurant
Andre to be here with us.
[APPLAUSE]
Chef Andre's new book,
"Octaphilosophy,"
just released this week.
So we're one the first
readers to get a copy.
And he's also going to
share a lot of the secrets
from this book during this talk.
Chef Andre has been trained by
many of the world's top chefs,
and he is also among
the best chefs.
And he mainly learned his
culinary skills in France,
and he has brought the
taste of south France
back to Singapore in his
restaurant Andre in Chinatown.
Yes.
And Restaurant Andre has been
one of the top 50 restaurants
in the world, and one of
the top three in Asia.
[APPLAUSE]
Before we start the
talk, we're going
to play that creative
process from restaurant Andre
again, just for us to have
a look at how he creates
some of the famous dishes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-It's kind of a traditional
fine dining sequence that
happends in the main course.
You've got have
the cheese course.
When it first
arrived in Singapore,
I realize that at the
beginning, although you
have the best French
artisan cheese,
not everybody appreciates it.
Everyone enjoys every single
course until the cheese.
The cheese course seems
like one of the courses
where we can not do anything.
In respect of the French
tradition and sequence,
we would like to keep it.
But how can I inject something
that really belongs here?
So I decided to do
a look-alike cheese
course of dehydrated milk
bavarois in the dry aging room.
It's exactly like cheese making.
So we put it on the grill so
it had the nice ventilation
and it dries it slowly.
And I would flip it
on different sides
until it half dehyrdrated and
created the crust over it.
The inside is milky,
like a Camembert.
We see ourselves
as like an artisan
because we're making
our own cheese, which
is something very farmer style.
So we get the hay from
France-- really nice hay
with a lot of
different herbs inside.
And then we dry
them and roast it.
And then we make a hay ice
cream served the Camembert.
For those that don't appreciate
the traditional artisan cheese,
they could have something
that is similar-- very light,
very refreshing, very
sweet and totally unique.
I spend most of my time in the
south of France, Medditeranean.
I want to create that
really, very classy--
or you can say Medditeranean
on Spanish dish.
You have a charcoal grill squid
with piquillos smoked pepper
and olive oil.
A very simple dish.
When I was thinking of the
dish, what makes you remember?
Is it the squid itself
or it's the combination
of the squid and the
piquillos or what is it?
It's that smokiness.
It's that burning edge that
makes the whole dish to life
Nothing can be replaced
with that burning
flavor from the charcoal.
So what about if I want to have
an ultimate dish, that I just
eat the charcoal.
And that's where I start
to really work on it.
And we make fried
charcoal dough.
So we serve burning charcoal
with the friend charcoal dough.
And then we serve a piquillos
dip with the charcoal squid.
In fact, the squid, or
the piquillos in a dish
they are just
accessories in a way.
We designed that in
the middle of the menu.
So sometimes when you see a
normal menu, you start it small
and the portion gets bigger, and
bigger, and bigger, and bigger.
For a long menu, sometimes
half way through it,
it's getting heavy.
You're getting tired.
If half way, we can
have a break or we
can have something fun--
that kind of lightening
up, freshening up a little bit.
And then we restart again.
Every night, we have a
guest finish very late.
Most of the time they finish
at 11:00, 11:30, 12:00,
or even the later sometimes.
I just feel that I want to
serve something like breakfast,
and then say, hey guys.
You've got to go.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's breakfast time.
Kaya toast is the
breakfast in Singapore.
It's white toast--
grilled white toast.
And then you have kaya, which
is a coconut and pandan.
Then you have one slice
of cold salted butter.
And that's it.
That's kaya toast.
Well, at the end of the meal,
you serve coffee of course.
So coffee served
with the kaya toast--
that's kind of the
ending or a beginning.
But yet I don't
want to just serve
kaya toast like anywhere else.
I still want to keep
my French background.
I started to make white
toast look like macaroons.
We do it exactly the same way.
We grill it, make our own kaya.
And then you must have one
icy cold salted butter inside.
If you're eating with your eyes
open, it's kind of a macaroon.
But if you're eating
with your eyes closed,
it's exactly the
same kaya toast.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END  PLAYBACK]
ANDRE CHIANG: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
So OK.
Good afternoon, guys.
So today I'll be here to talk
about Octaphilosophy and also
why we're doing
everything and what's
behind it or our
thinking process.
So the video that you saw just
now, it's just a few dishes
is that is why we do it.
And I guess a lot of you have
already been to the restaurant
and you know what we do.
Some of you don't know.
But that doesn't matter.
So today we're going to go
start from the beginning.
As you can see, the
Octaphilosophy--
what is Octaphilosophy?
Why the octagon is
so important to us
and why did everything
come from it?
So just starting with
Octaphilosophy-- Octaphilosophy
is something that when I
first started-- before I
started Restaurant Andre.
My parents are Taiwanese.
I was born in Taiwan.
And I grew up in France.
I arrived in Singapore
eight years ago.
That's how everything started.
And we wanted to
come back to Asia
and start up our own business.
So I was thinking, OK.
So how to tell people that
this is Andre's cuisine--
this is not Taiwanese cuisine.
This is not French cuisine.
This is something
that belongs to me
and it collects everything
everywhere I go.
And it becomes my
own style of cuisine.
So I started going back to
look at everything that I did,
that I created
the past 20 years.
And I realized I don't
have anything fixed.
Everywhere I go,
I collect ideas.
It becomes.
I get inspired by
different things.
I grew up in an artist family.
My mom was a chef.
My father is a
Chinese calligrapher.
My brother is an actor.
My sister is a
clothing designer.
And I'm very into
pottery and sculpture.
So in a way, we were
trained since we
were little to appreciate
each other's work--
to appreciate the
beautiful things in life
in different forms.
So that means a lot to me.
And so I look at
everything that I've
created in the past 20 years.
And I realized
these eight elements
that are constantly repeating
in my creations-- it's
just like, OK.
Our hairstyle, our
makeup-- if you
look at what your picture was
five years or 10 years ago,
you'll say, oh my God.
I got a hairstyle like that.
And my make up is horrible.
But at that time, you
feel so good about it.
Yeah?
So same thing for me.
I said, you know I constantly
change my style or taste.
But the one thing that
never changed probably
is my favorite color.
Yeah.
So that's the essence.
So when I look at everything
that I've created,
these eight elements
are constantly
repeating in my creation.
So I said, yeah.
So how to tell people that
this is Andre's cuisine--
these eight elements
become so important.
Because no matter where I
go, no matter what I create,
or when I create, these
elements-- eight elements
are always there.
So that's Andre.
So we just try to give
it a name and give it
a reason so people can
understand it easily,
that this is Octo-philosphy--
that this is what we do.
So when we first started,
I always was constantly
asking myself the
question, all the time,
are we moving forward or
are we moving backwards?
Oh by the way, you guys can
have a lunch [INAUDIBLE]
while eating.
It was so cool.
[LAUGHTER]
I like it here.
Yeah.
So where were we at?
I should have one
too, like, you know.
So yeah, when I first
started, I constantly
asked myself questions--
are we moving forward
or are we moving backwards
with everything that we create?
Yeah.
So if you think about
a dining experience,
if you go to a casual
restaurant, and you go.
You sit down.
And you order.
And you eat.
If you're at a fine dining
restaurant, you sit down.
And then they're going to ask
you 50 questions before you
reach your first course.
Oh you have to select
this, and select that.
You want this.
You want one that.
We have 250 selections
of teas and things.
So can I start?
OK.
And every dish, there were
so many things in the there.
And the menu, it's so
beautifully written.
So what is that?
Is that the ultimate
dining experience?
Or are we just forcing the
guests to catch all that?
Can we just keep
everything simple,
and leave this space
for imagination?
Not giving you the
whole book and say, OK.
You have to read through it.
Can we leave this space
for the imagination,
for the creativity?
So that's what I
think-- that if I just
put these eight
words on my menu,
and I leave the rest to
the guests to discover.
It's not empty.
It just leaves a room for you
to put in your imagination,
or you feel that
your answer to that
question-- you filled in
the space of your dining
experience.
And only the dining
experience that fits you
is the ultimate
dining experience.
So that's how I started
out the philosophy.
So these eight elements, later
we're going to go through.
Today I just took eight
pictures inside the book.
So we can just go through it.
And I'll just show you
what it is roughly.
So we've got these
eight elements.
So how do I create every dish?
So for me, the eight
elements, the eight dishes,
it's like a movie.
It's like a movie you have.
You sit down for two and
a half hours for a movie.
And it's exactly the same
time for a dining experience.
So I'm the director.
And how am I going
to create this
two and a half hours that
you feel this excitement,
that you have good
guys and bad guys,
and the other
funny guy came out.
So how do I prepare this script
so that this two and a half
hours aren't bored?
It's always up the beat.
So eight elemnts-- they are
all different characters.
So nothing is related
to each other.
And there's no
particular sequence.
So you have a good guy.
You have a bad guy.
You have these eight
different characters.
How do you create these
eight different characters?
In one of the pages
of the book, you
have the sketch, this
octagon analysis.
So what is the octagon analysis?
We look at every dish and
then we give them a DNA.
OK?
So I prepared something
just real quick just now.
So you the eight elements.
Maybe I'll put it here.
OK.
So I just drew an octagon.
And this is what we do.
We give a DNA for
every single dish.
OK.
You see originality,
imagination, craft, taste,
character, simplicity,
emotion, and structure.
OK.
So you will have a dish
that focuses on structure.
Or you have a certain dish that
focuses on-- sometimes it's
you have to eat it
with hands and this
is one of the experiences.
Or this dish is inspired
by my mom's salad.
Or this is a dish that focuses
on textures or art design.
So every dish comes
from a different source
of inspiration.
Yeah.
So we identified every
single dish with a DNA.
OK.
So that's that octagon
is the DNA for the dish.
And so if we have eight of
them, to put them together,
they should become
a complete octagon.
That means every dish that
gives a different angle--
some dish focuses on structures,
some focus on imagination.
You see how they overlapped.
Yeah?
So I guess as a chef, or not--
or any one of you-- sometimes
we never look at what we do.
We thought that, OK.
This is cool.
This I created.
And every single
dish is perfect.
But if you analyze it and
give every dish a DNA,
you realize that they
are all towards one side.
They are all very structural.
Or they are all very emotional.
But it's kind of
lacking something.
So some movies are very
consistent, at the same pace.
And some movies you have
different characters inside.
You have a very good pace.
Why?
Because we have to look inside.
What do we have?
Why is this so important?
Sometimes you have
a dish come in.
It's very visual.
It's very detailed.
And everything is
so perfectly done.
And the next course
can be so rustic
that you open the
husk of the corn
and you just eat it with hands.
And then the next course
can be something else--
totally simple.
So that's what I think-- that's
the ultimate dining experience.
And everything is
calculated, but that's only
behind the kitchen door.
We don't want to tell the
guests everything that I just
told you just now.
We want them to have
these eight words,
and just sit down and relax.
And they realize why
everything is so connected.
So yeah, it's been more than
what a chef's supposed to do.
And I don't know if
you respect this.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
I'll just continue.
So we're going to go into
the Octaphilosophy, so
the eight elements.
And it goes random.
So one of the
elements is unique.
OK So you might not
know what is this,
but I'm sure
everybody should know.
This is a carrot heart.
OK.
It's a heart of carrot.
So if we cut a carrot
length-wise, and then you see
there is one thin
yellow part inside.
And this is the carrot heart.
But we never knew that a carrot
heart could look like this.
So what is unique?
There is no such
thing as unique.
If you have a white sheep in
a whole bunch of black sheep,
the white sheep is unique.
And the black sheep
gets into the bunch
up white sheep-- it's unique.
And sometimes the uniqueness
comes to the right place
at the right time.
It doesn't matter what it is.
So this picture in the book--
I want to show you that a lot
of the things that we think
we know, but we don't.
We always peel or cut the
carrots like that-- peel
it with a peeler.
But if you cook the carrot,
the entire carrot by itself,
and then you open
it, you peel it
like you peel an orange skin.
And you will see this.
So change another
way of thinking.
And change a different
way to process a food,
and then you see it
in a different way.
And that's unique.
So there's nothing
really unique or not.
It's just how you do it.
We get used to the way
that we work all the time.
This has to be like that.
A carrot has to be like that.
You have to cut it in a way.
And you never see the
beauty of a carrot heart.
Then we use it.
We cure it.
And then we just show it.
And everybody says, wow.
Where did you get this carrot?
And it's from the
[INAUDIBLE] Market.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
So it's brainless.
But that's how I want
to show that it's
how we see this differently.
Second-- artisan.
So artisan is an
interesting element.
This one day that I went over
to Japan to see my friend.
He's a three Michelin Star,
one of the top restaurants
in Tokyo.
And he took me to see
this aubergine farmer.
And you know, the
Japanese are very
famous for their aubergines.
So then he said,
this guy is the best.
OK?
You gotta get the
vegetable from this guy.
So I went to see this guy.
And speechless-- his
produce is top notch.
And I said, can I buy this?
And he said no.
I said, then why
are you selling it?
[LAUGHTER]
He said my aubergine can
only be charcoal grilled
and served with a pinch of
salt. So he's telling me
how to cook the aubergine.
And I'm like, OK.
So if I say yes,
and then I come back
and I cook it a different
way, you would not know.
But one thing very
important is that at the end
I didn't manage to
get the aubergine.
Because I think the
saw it in my eyes
that this guy's not going to
cook it the way that I asked.
[LAUGHTER]
So he said no.
And then I go back and say, OK.
Oh my god.
You know one thing that
strikes me is a chef,
we never think about
what the farmer thinks.
They spend months,
maybe every day,
they go flip the vegetable.
They give them water.
They take care of it.
They say OK.
The weather is not good.
And then we cover it with
something you keep them warm.
It takes so much care
of every produce.
And they're so proud of it.
And what we do is, today I'm
going to do a carrot jelly.
And I just buy the carrot,
the best carrot I can get.
And I just squeeze
them into juice.
And I make a jelly.
So everything's gone.
All the work is gone.
And we never thought about it
as a chef because of our ego--
because we're so selfish.
We think that, I know
how to handle it.
But we never think of it in
a perspective of an artisan--
that they want to
do deliver-- they're
so proud of their produce.
And they want to make sure
they deliver all the way,
from the moment that
it grows until the end,
that it can be served perfectly.
We never thought about it.
We just think that we're
good at what we do.
And I'm going to
take care of it.
So that gave me an idea,
that every day and every menu
that I serve, I want to have one
dish that doesn't belong to me.
I want to have one dish that's
dedicated to the artisan.
So I want them to tell me
how you want to cook it,
how I can deliver
the best out of it.
If he said that I'm going
to grill it and then give
a pinch of salt, then that
will be my foundation.
I will see how I can deliver
the way that he wants to.
Or if he says that just
slice them and dip it
in a bit of vinegar and just
eat it with hands or whatever.
So can I just have
one dish that doesn't
belong to Andre in a menu
that's dedicated to the artisan?
At least that's
something that I can do,
and not to forget all the
hard work from the artisan.
So that's how I want to have
one of the elements that's
dedicated to the artisan.
And so in this picture,
you see the artisan's hand
and he's holding something.
It should be a carrot.
It should be an orange.
It should be an aubergine.
But we cannot identify what it
is already because it's been
processed.
So in this picture, I want
to say that a lot of chefs
that we say, OK.
We are natural.
We use organic products.
We try to preserve
it as much as we can.
We cook it as light as we can.
But are we really natural?
Yeah.
Are we really delivering
what the farmer's message is?
Or are you just
pretentiously natural?
Yeah.
So that's the picture.
In fact, that is
watermelon skin.
So we cure the watermelon
skin and it becomes
one of the dishes in the menu.
So yeah, that's that
elements of artisan.
Next element-- south.
South is an interesting element.
It refers to the south of France
because I spent most of my time
in France.
I arrived in the south
of France in Mont Pelier.
That's where I spent 10 years of
my time in the south of France.
So in the south of France,
what I learned is not only OK.
We use a lot of seafood.
We rarely use meat-- very light
cooking, acidity, freshness.
People are generous.
So that's what I learned--
not only how to cook,
but how to live my life.
Mont Pelier-- where I lived
is just about 40 minutes
to the Mediterranean Sea.
So that's where I spent my time
learning about the culture.
And you will see that the people
from the south of France, they
never think about-- OK.
My chef never taught me
or said this is what I do.
This is what I like.
Or this is what
I want you to do.
He would tell me this
is the south of France.
This is how we eat in
the south of France.
And this is when
we have to eat it.
This is how we eat it
in the south of France.
This is how we cook it
So it's not about him,
it's about the whole south
of French cuisine.
So for this picture,
it's the fish
that we pitched on every--
this is one of the pictures
that you'll see in the book.
Every ticket is when we bid
in the [INAUDIBLE] market
in Japan.
So you have to pick the fish.
And then after you got the
fish, you put a ticket on it.
And they list a ticket
of [INAUDIBLE] Andre.
So that's 632, that's our fish.
That's our ticket.
So when we picked fish,
the best fish that we want,
we would put the
ticket on there.
So that's becomes yours.
So we use a lot of seafood
in the south of France.
This picture-- I just want to
show that-- everybody asks me,
oh Andre, is that
French cuisine?
Is that Japanese cuisine?
Is that a Taiwanese
Asian twist or what?
For me, it's really
difficult for me
to categorize what
we do, what I do.
But it does not matter.
For me, if you look
at the fish, we
saw we got our fish from Japan,
from the [INAUDIBLE] market.
And we give them a ticket.
But there is no
border in the sea.
They just happened
to swim to Japan.
And you pick it out.
And then that's a Japanese fish.
Or that should be-- pick it out
an the Mediterranean Sea, then
that's a Mediterranean fish.
That's a French fish.
OK.
So am I Taiwanese, French,
Singaporean, or what?
It does not matter for me.
I don't know how to categorize
the thing that I cook.
But I want people to enjoy
it, enjoy the experience.
It doesn't matter where you
come from-- south of France.
Texture.
For me, when you
talk about texture,
most of the time
we talk about one
produce in a different
dimension, different process,
that focuses on one dish.
So in this case, this dish is
a frozen white truffle bisque.
And for me, what is texture?
How do you create a texture?
When you look at a piece
of stone, and then you say,
oh that's texture.
But how do you feel the texture?
Only when you have a
contrast-- only when you
have a smooth surface or
you have a smooth hand.
And then you touch the stone.
Only when you have a
contract, you have texture.
Only when you have
a very soft surface
and you touch a
very rough surface,
and then you feel the texture.
Or hot and cold.
So how do you feel cold?
Only when your
temperature is warmer.
So there's always a contrast.
So contrast is texture.
And another meaning for me
for texture is time traveling.
So we create-- how to
create a texture is time.
So maybe you leave it under
the sun, the same produce,
you leave it under
the sun for 24 hours.
And that changed the texture.
Or you leave it for three months
and that changed the texture.
You bake it in the
oven for 10 minutes
at 250 degrees, that
changes the texture.
So texture is time traveling.
It's about time.
So this is the
dish where you can
see-- it's a handcrafted
wooden ball by an artisan.
And on the top is an
ultra-modern capsule.
And he's trying to capture that
contrast, and also the time
traveling.
And inside you have the
ultramodern frozen bisque
of a white truffle.
And you have an original truffle
that's just right next to it.
So for me that contrast tells
you what is texture about.
Pure.
So this is one of the
dishes-- it's a finished dish.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be like that.
[LAUGHTER]
So white on white-- obviously
that's pure-- white on white.
So here we have two
messages for you.
First is that purely pretentious
or pretentiously pure?
Sometimes when we
have an image, we
have something
really really simple.
And we though yeah, that's pure.
That's simplicity.
Just like a beautiful
white t-shirt,
and you think that it's
very pure and simple.
But behind that white
t-shirt that you bought,
there might be a huge, gigantic,
dirty factory behind it.
So are we pure?
Or it's potentially pure--
for everything that we do.
For me, pure is you leave
a space, message to unfold.
So it is a complete picture.
It's not an empty space.
For example, in
our restaurant, we
do this pure element of a dish.
I was thinking that nowadays we
use everything with seasoning.
We season everything.
You need a pinch of
salt. You need a dip.
You need a dressing,
a sauce, a puree.
Everything needs a seasoning.
We've been eating seasonings
more than the produce itself.
Even when we think we're
healthy-- we're having salads.
We're having a carrot stick.
Even a carrot stick,
you need a dip.
So are we eating the dip or are
we eating the carrot itself?
We can't even identify
what is the flavor
of the carrot itself.
We need something to go with it.
But what is a complete-- so
if you're having a carrot
stick by itself, it doesn't mean
that you are missing something.
It's still a complete flavor.
It's just our brain tells
us we need something.
If you look at this
dish, if you're like
do you need a sauce or
something to go with it?
Why?
It is a complete dish.
It is a complete flavor.
You don't need seasoning.
So it's a reflection for us
to think when we have a space,
and we need that space
to leave it as it is.
And we're asked to put
in our imagination, put
in our creativity--
to fill up the space.
There's nothing missing here.
So for me, that's a purity.
That's a purity.
So in our restaurant we do have
a dish that uses no seasoning,
no-- just purely a combination
of the produce itself.
No electric consumptions,
no fire, no cooking.
So this is one dish--
elements of salt.
OK.
This is very interesting.
Salvation, salary, salad--
salt is the key to life.
In the old times we used salt
to keep us away from demons.
We used salt as
currency to exchange.
And we used salt
to preserve food.
So salt is the
beginning of everything.
That's how important salt is.
And turn black and
white into color.
The first seasoning
that we know-- so salt
has been very important.
For me, we are always thinking
that can we have a flavor
that everybody understands?
Whether it's lemongrass, or
it's chili, or it's curry--
I don't know-- a cheese.
Somehow it's trapped
in a certain boundary.
But can we have one dish
that everybody understands?
So I was thinking salt.
It's not just the physical salt,
but the depth of saltiness.
What I mean is for example,
soy sauce, fish sauce, ham,
anchovy, and sea
water or seaweed.
They are all different
depths of saltiness.
So that means that if you
have a piece of carrot--
why do I keep talking
about carrots?--
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Anyway, you have
another piece of carrot.
You use a different depth
of-- let's stop looking
at seasoning horizontally.
Let's look at it vertically.
So a different
depth of saltiness.
So if you season a
carrot with the things
that I just mentioned--
different depths of saltiness.
You put all these
things to the carrot.
You still taste
the carrot itself,
but the flavor changes complete.
And I think that's
the beauty of it--
that you can still taste
the produce itself,
but in a different dimension.
And I think it's really sexy--
that people will understand
the meaning of the depth.
If you put these five
ingredients-- fish sauce,
ham, anchovy, seaweed--
we put them in one place.
You still taste the five
different depths of saltiness.
They won't cancel each other.
And so that is my
source of inspiration
for the elements of salt.
And we use no salt added.
So that's a dish that we
don't use the physical salt.
Instead we use different
depths of saltiness
to enhance the produce that
we're trying to highlight.
Terroir.
So terroir is about
the land, the soil,
the character from a particular
space-- time of produce.
So in our restaurant, we have
one dish that we try to-- we're
trying to portray the
character of terroir--
the soil, the stone, the
character, the nature.
So we buried our meat
inside a soil of bitterness.
So we have coffee
beans, cacao, licorice,
and you put a hot stone inside.
And we cover it.
And we bake it in the oven.
So in a very old school
pressure cooker--
instead of cooking every meat
in a plastic bag, nowadays
you see.
So for me, that is trying
to reflect that question
that I said at the beginning.
One day, I was just
betting with my team.
And I said, are
we moving forward
or are we moving backwards?
Nowadays we cook our
meat in a plastic bag
and then we say
that is super cool.
But are we giving any
flavor to the meat itself?
If you look at the old times,
how people cooked their meat--
they charcoal grilled it.
And then they cook
it in a pastry.
They cook it in
the dough of bread.
Or they cook it in some crust.
And it gives so much flavor.
Even just frying in a
frying pan with butter,
garlic, and rosemary gives so
much flavor to the meat itself.
And nowadays we just
cook it like that.
So are we really moving forward?
Sometimes we just never
look closely at the things
that we do.
And we think that are we
moving forward or backwards?
It doesn't give any
flavor to meat itself.
So terroir is a
dish that I always
want to go back to the
original place where we are,
where the flavor belongs to.
Then memory-- so this is a very
famous dish in our restaurant.
So one day, one of the guests
asked me, Andre-- Every night,
after I serve the
main course, I go
to see the guests at the table
and see how are they doing.
One of the guests one
day asked me, so Andre,
what's your childhood
memory of sweets?
And I stood there for 10
seconds and I said, nothing.
Nothing-- I couldn't think
of anything that I liked.
Oh my god.
I have no childhood memories.
[LAUGHTER]
It's horrible.
I couldn't think of
anything that I liked.
And that kind of
stuck on my chest
for a very, very long time.
And so one day I was with my
wife and we were watching TV.
And I said, hey, you know,
this is one thing I really
like is the raw cake dough.
I don't like cake.
I don't like
pancakes, or ganache,
or cupcakes or anything.
I'm a very savory person.
So even sometimes my
dessert is savory.
Like we use green pea.
We use beet root, celery--
are very savory person.
So I say, yeah.
Every time a family member
when the prepared a cake,
and there's always the last
bit of the raw cake dough.
And that's my favorite part.
And I don't want to the final
result. So I said, yeah.
So that's my childhood memory.
OK?
So I'm going to tell people
that's my childhood memory.
So I will prepare-- I want
to do a raw cake batter
preparation just like that.
Oh by the way, that's
the final product.
[LAUGHTER]
That's what we serve on
the table, seriously.
This is not just an image.
This is how we serve
in Restaurant Andre.
And you have it like that.
So I want people to just
put the egg in the milk.
And then you have butter, flour.
And you mix everything
together and eat it.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Are you serious?
ANDRE CHIANG: Yes.
I'm very serious.
[LAUGHTER]
It's called a DIY cake.
That's what we serve.
So I say-- you know,
that I can tell people
that that's the process.
That's the thing that I
like in my childhood memory.
So I went back and I did the
cake batter-- a real cake
batter-- and I try it.
And try to catch my childhood
memorr-- my favorite part
of my memory when I was a kid.
And I tried the raw cake dough.
And I said, it doesn't
taste good at all.
It tastes horrible.
But why I cached that
memory as my child memory--
is that because of
the raw cake dough?
Maybe not.
Is that the favorite
taste that I like?
No.
But why is that something
that stuck on my mind
and is something I remember--
is that's the moment when
my family gets together.
And they will prepare the cake.
And then I'll wait here
until they're finished.
And I see the last bit
and I'll steal the tongs.
And then I eat it.
So what is memory?
Sometimes it might not be
the best thing in a world.
But that's something that
is stuck on your memory.
And every time you think about
it, that's this sweetest part.
That's the best
part of the meal.
So that's why we decided
to keep this dessert.
Of course everything
is well-prepared.
You're not going to
have a rotten egg,
and with the milk, and cook
the thing on the table.
But yeah.
That's one of the things
we do in our restaurants--
one of the very popular
dessert in our restaurant.
So I guess that's
about Octaphilosophy.
So at the end-- I want to
say this is what we do.
And I hope that you all find
want your eight elements that
mean a lot to you.
Maybe not eight--
12, 16, anything.
But most important is we don't
travel and look for ideas.
We don't look at what other
people do and look for ideas.
The idea is in you.
It's in everything that you do.
And find the essence.
It can be eight.
It can be six.
It can be-- maybe your
idea came from oh my god.
I got out and have a smoke.
That's your Octaphilosophy.
Find you eight elements
that means of lot to you.
And the rest I think
will just come naturally.
So discover your Octaphilosophy
and I hope your enjoy the book.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: And now we
can have maybe one or two Q&A.
And then afterwards,
if you got the book,
Chef Andre will be here
for signing the book.
ANDRE CHIANG: Yes.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So I've been to
your restaurant many times.
I celebrate most of my beautiful
moments at your restaurant.
So when you talk
about your dish,
I think it's time traveling
is the fois gras dish that you
make-- [INAUDIBLE] every day.
And I saw the uniqueness
in your experience
with the black strip.
I think the decor in your
restaurant-- and [INAUDIBLE]
star and the big mirror
on your third floor.
[LAUGHTER]
And I also know
your wife as well.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDRE CHIANG: Uh.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I've been to
your restaurant many times.
I try to understand
how you view a brand.
Are you going to
continue to stay unique?
Or are you going to be another
Joel Robuchon or Daniel Boulud.
Are you going to
franchise your restaurant?
ANDRE CHIANG: OK.
That's a very good question.
Definitely not.
There's only one Andre.
And Andre has to be Andre.
Right?
So it's hard to--
personally, I'm
someone that is very, very
against that kind of pace.
So although we have--
along the way in my career,
I've come across so
many great talents.
So many great chefs--
that just like
when we were I first started,
and no one knows who Andre is,
but you have someone,
good friends that say,
Andre you're really talented.
You should have
your own restaurant.
I'll lend you money and you
open your own restaurant.
When you have money, you
return it back to me.
That's how I started.
Along the way I met so
many great talents--
so many great chefs-- that I
think that they shouldn't just
work for me under Andre.
So I want them to open
their own restaurants
and they have their
own brand that
has nothing to do with Andre.
So for us, we started
six years ago.
We have Restaurant Andre.
And now we have in total
three other restaurants
in Singapore-- one in
Paris, on in Teipei.
But none of them are
under the name of Andre.
And my card doesn't have
all these restaurants name.
You don't find it
on the website.
None of the restaurants
serve the same dish,
the same crockery, the same
design, the same pricing.
Everything is completely fresh.
And I think that's
something important of us--
is every restaurant
needs to have
their own DNA,
their own concept.
And it's always the
chef is in front.
For me, I'm just the supporter.
And I think they should
do their own thing
and they should be the
man of their own concept.
That's actually
the least thing I
can do that to support
his great talent.
So there will be only one Andre.
And you won't see Andre
Sydney, Andre Istanbul.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Lionel.
Thank you for sharing with us.
I've been to your restaurant
once, not as many times as him.
And I really like the
way that you think.
And just from hearing
you share this,
I can see the passion
that you have.
I'm curious on your journey, how
did you know from the start--
or did you know from the start
that you wanted to be a chef?
And how did know this
was your calling?
Tell us a little bit of
more about that journey.
ANDRE CHIANG: OK.
So as you know, I grew
up in an artist family.
So I didn't know that
I would become a chef.
I wanted to be a potter.
I wanted to be a potter
and I want to do sculpture.
That's what I liked
when I was little.
My brother and my sister, they
are much-- seven years apart
from me-- so they are
much older than I.
So they already found
what they want to do.
And so my mom was running
a restaurant in Japan--
a Chinese restaurant--
and so she was like,
that's the last
kid that probably
will take over my business.
I'd better try to
guide him somehow.
And make sure he doesn't
go in the other direction.
So yeah.
That's how I thought OK.
I'll be the one to take
up my mom's business.
And I kind of liked cooking.
So I left Taiwan when I was 13.
And I stayed two
years with my mom.
And I learned the
things from her.
And so I can eventually
take over the restaurant.
And after two years I decided
to learn something different.
And I said, OK.
I'm going to learn
French cuisine.
So in fact I don't know-- I
don't have an idea that I want
to be best chef in the world.
I want to do French cuisine.
I don't have an idea.
I just said OK.
I want to take over
my mom's restaurant.
And I better learn
something-- not only from her,
but from the best of the best.
So I can bring back different
idea and try to help my mom
and change the concept and
learn how to be better.
Once I arrived in France--
it's completely different.
It's totally opposite of
what I learned from my mom.
First, that's my mom.
Second it's a
Chinese restaurant.
So she'll teach you how
to make things crispy,
how to make that skin shiny and
how to make it crispy and hot.
So it's very, very
technical, very technical.
And second thing is
she said, OK Andre.
don't?
Try to be creative.
Don't try to be funny.
Just do the thing that
I asked you to do.
This is the recipe.
OK.
So I don't want you
to change anything.
I want you to continue.
I don't want you
to change anything.
And I went to France.
And it's a totally opposite way.
My chef asked me, so
what do you think?
What do you think?
You like it?
You don't?
Why?
And when you receive the
vegetables and you smell it.
And he said tomorrow, I'll
take you to see the farmer.
You'll see the farmer.
And you say, OK this
is Uncle Gilbert
And this his vegetables.
And he lives with
his two daughters.
And it's so emotional.
Everything is so emotional.
So when you create a dish,
you think about Uncle Gilbert
and his two daughters.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's very different.
It's very, very different.
So I say, wow.
That's the heart I
delved into-- all
of the process, all the creative
process of French cooking.
The culture, the history--
everything is connected.
So I talked to my mom, I said
that's something I want to do.
That's really-- I feel so free.
I feel I can tell
people what I think.
I can put my
imagination in the dish.
And it's all connected
to everything.
So my mom said OK.
If you like it, just continue.
And so that's how
I just continued
my path of French cuisine.
And I just stayed
there for 17 years.
So I never really planned
like five years, 10 years down
the road, what am I going to do.
So I'm still doing what I do.
Right now I never think
of doing other things.
[INAUDIBLE] I like it.
Everybody has one thing that he
does better than other people.
For me, it's cooking.
So I wanted to continue and do
what I do, and share my idea.
And sometimes I feel
I think differently.
So I need my team
to balance me out.
So yeah.
Thank you.
OK?
Another one?
AUDIENCE: Is your mom's
restaurant still running?
[LAUGHTER]
ANDRE CHIANG: No,
because they're
looking for a head chef.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
My mom retired.
Once she knows that the
son is not coming back
to take over the restaurant.
And so she said--
the three of us, me,
my brother, and my
sister-- they're
all good at what they do.
So my mom can retire.
There's no need to--
and then she said, OK.
Then I'll just retire.
She left but she was here
for my lunch yesterday.
And then she went back
to Taipei this morning
before I came here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: One
last question, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Andre.
I've been to your
restaurant before.
And it's fantastic.
So today is the
highlight of my day.
And my question is really
around your creative process.
Your food is amazingly created.
Have there been
times where you must
stuck in the creative process?
And what do you do to
get out of that rut?
ANDRE CHIANG: OK.
Just a quick story-- this
one day, a couple of years
back-- I think it's the second
year that the Restaurant
Andre opened.
So one day, we have
the guests arrive.
And the restaurant is packed.
And more than half
of the restaurant
is all repeated guests.
So all of repeated
guests are always
wanting to try a few new
dishes and different things.
As I start to do--
and I said oh my god.
Everybody's a repeated
guest in this room.
So I was said, OK.
The kitchen is
running like crazy.
And everybody is running around.
And I said stop.
We're going to change
the entire menu tonight.
And everybody's like what?
Because we are in the middle
of the service and everyone's
running.
I said we're going to change the
entire menu because we have to.
And everybody stopped for
four five seconds-- OK.
And they run the other way.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the moment that--
before I always think back
I can do everything.
I can create.
I can execute everything
the way I want it.
And I can do it 100%
But that was the moment
that I suddenly realized
that with my team,
we can reach 120%.
It's something that I cannot
do without their support.
I can have thousands of ideas.
But I need good execution.
And that's how fast-- they
can come in and say, OK.
Chef, later we're
going to do this.
And we're going to do that.
And later, OK you
want the duck dish.
OK.
Then we can do this
and we can do that.
And that's when we put
everything together.
And I feel so powerful.
The moment that I
feel so powerful
is when I'm in the
kitchen because I
have my whole team with me.
And they're more
critical than I do.
They say chef, no.
I don't like this.
We should best do this.
They're more critical than I do.
They give me a lot of pressure.
That's how I enjoy it.
For me, it's really
the teamwork.
I work a lot with me team.
We sit down.
We talk about it.
We talk about different ideas.
So it's not just Andre.
We have a good team that
supports every idea that I do.
We're not the hierarchy.
We're not the on man
show and say I want this.
And get it done.
No.
We discuss.
In our kitchen, we have
one small white board.
It's probably this size.
And everybody can write
a unique combination
of flavors or anything on it.
So we pass by that white
board 300 times a day.
So every time you walk
by you'll see someone
wrote duck egg and
vanilla and lobster.
So you're like whoa.
What is that?
It makes you think
Is that a dessert?
Is that a dish?
So I think maybe
is an appetizer.
And he might thinks
it's a main course.
So everybody can write
the ideas that they have,
or just three components, not
detail on the white board.
And so that's how we
get all the ideas.
And we pass by that
white board every day.
And in a book, there is one
picture on the white board--
a dirty white board.
And we all put our idea
as we pass by every day.
And that's where I get
our inspiration from.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]